ok
aber ich kann jetzt die große freude den
wechsel
erster gegen spanien vorgestellt
er ist profi
geleitet wird das gespräch in einem
telefonat gesagt und oenning und diana
district und philosophie studiert und
seine wissenschaft historische die
sensationsgier gelte seine agitation
stehen konstruktionsprozess den schritt
seit anfang 2010 sind und bessere
deutsche philologie an der universität
gültigen im jahr 2017 erschienen wilhelm
von humboldt reden zu viel und wir sind
jetzt sehr gespannt was genau mit dem
tippen lesen digital hier vorne haben
wir keinen eindruck davon zu hören mich
gut ja ja
guten morgen meine damen und herren
lesen digital sie wissen alle wesen ist
für das lernen einschließlich des
lernens zb in mathematischer relationen
extrem wichtig sozusagen die mutter des
lernens und wir alle wissen der zustand
des lesens ist sobald das wort digital
im raum ist sehr schlecht
das klingt dann zum beispiel so geht es
nicht weiter
das hängt das ist der klassiker
[Musik]
gar nichts mehr
mit eingefroren
[Musik]
jetzt job
und der sound mit der diese kritik
vorgetragen wird wird etwa von dem und
front terrible der amerikanischen
literatur dann so formuliert und über
das duell es werden noch weitere länder
um carrie bradshaw und gemeint sind die
jungen menschen heute noch dominique
bussereau erste break
wer also keine lust mehr keiner schreibt
mir literatur ist tot
das ist einfach alles vorbei ist völlig
normal
gucken sie sich an was der affe
kulturelle bildung etwas differenzierter
darstellt dann kann zu recht darauf
verweisen dass youtube längst die umwelt
auch der lesenden generation heute ist
und nicht mehr das buch sie kennen
wahrscheinlich diese zahlen ich muss da
gar nicht im einzelnen darauf eingehen
das ist einfach youtube das leitmedium
der 12 bis 19 jährigen grob
zusammengefasst und schließlich haben
der börsenverein des deutschen
buchhandels letztes jahr mit viel
presseecho festgestellt dass vor allem
die jungen also zwischen 20 bis 49 das
ist eine zahl es sind jungen
interessant aber die also jedenfalls
zählen diese aufzeichnungen 29 30 19 30
eine von üben käufer zahlen von über 30
prozent verlust von leserinnen und leser
so hat man das dann interpretiert und
hermann liebmann und anderen das über 30
prozent der jungen menschen eigentlich
nicht mehr interessiert sind bücher zu
kaufen und sie können sich vorstellen
was in den fonds da war los war jetzt
gab es die schulen spannung immerhin
300.000 sind wieder gekommen aber viele
millionen leserinnen und leser sind
schon verloren also das ist alles vorbei
mit dem buch und wir müssen gar nicht
mehr darüber reden das ist für die
schulen relevant und kolleginnen wie
manfred schneider und andere ob das
jetzt nur so ganz exemplarisch die
formulieren tasse kritik dann auch in
demselben toren das eben in einer
umgebung fortschreitender lebens
erleichterung den aufwand an zeit
konzentration und vorstellungskraft eben
von der jungen generation niemand mehr
aufbringen mögen die ein gedicht ein
roman eines sale eine novelle verlangen
also wir haben die alten professoren
dazu darf ich mich jetzt auch zellen die
die büchern pflegen und die das noch
wissen wie wichtig helga wm ist und
diese junge generation die das nicht sie
wissen natürlich und da könnte ich mir
jetzt leicht machen dass das ein topos
ist der bildungs kritik sein plattform
und damit wäre die sache schnell vom
tisch
man kann sagen
eigenes genre geworden der kulturkritik
also in deutschland kennen
wahrscheinlich alle manfred spitzer der
jedes jahr ein neues buch in dieser
richtung rausgibt im amerikanischen mehr
wären wohl wir machen weil es da mal
einer erklärung
da dabei und auch deren rezeption in
deutschland durch die faz war eben genau
in dieser richtung des digitale
verblödete generation unsere jungs
werden alle die konto
das ist also die conclusio das können
sie natürlich in der bildungsgeschichte
lange nachlesen wir wollen also da ein
bisschen genauer angucken stimmt das und
ich will am anfang ein paar daten geben
wie hat sich lesen tatsächlich
entwickelt sofern wir darüber überhaupt
daten haben und die datenlage ist
natürlich sehr schlecht wir gucken uns
dann an ich versucht dann zu zeigen dass
lesen gibt aber es funktioniert
tatsächlich nicht digital songs
funktioniert in einer digitalen umwelt
was ein unterschied ist und spricht dann
die folgen die das für die forschung hat
weil wir eine andere form von lese
forschung brauchen als wir sie
vielleicht klassischerweise haben
zunächst also mal zu einem partner
hatten in sachen gewesen
reading und leeds wurde 2009 der große
lese bericht in den usa
das national
for the arts and humanities
überschrieben weil seit mehr als 30
jahren des niedergangs von leserzahlen
zum ersten mal die zahlen wieder
gestiegen sind und zwar über die so
wichtige markierung der dass mindestens
die hälfte aller amerikanerinnen und
amerikaner mindestens einmal im jahr ein
buch gelesen haben
mindestens im jahr über 55 prozent sehen
es die 50 prozent marke ist einfach
psychologisch wichtig noch besser zählen
die zahl der jugendlichen aus also genau
in dem moment als das internet die
gesellschaft durchdringt etwa mit dem
jahrtausendwechsel und dann auch das
iphone und die digitalen welten kommen
steigt das lesen noch wichtiger ist dass
die zahl absolut steigt denn die zahl
der amerikaner ist durch starke
migration erheblich gewachsen aber wir
haben auch in gruppen
aus lateinamerika mittelamerika kommen
steigende leserinnen und leser zahlen
und auch das notorisch lese schwache
geschlecht also die jungs männer lesen
wieder näher
und sie lesen vor allem romane was ist
das meistgelesene chance noch schlimmer
sieht es aus für die kritiker des
sogenannten und kultur verfalls dass die
benutzung von bibliotheken und vor allem
das lesen von büchern unter der jungen
generation in den usa viel besser ist
als unter den älteren das ist hier also
economies beziehungsweise und damit
aktiv dabei ist also das ist der
sozusagen think tank im amerikanischen
bildungswesen wenn sich die zahlen
anschauen um 18 bis 29 jährigen und fünf
und sechs älteren ansehnlichen egal
welche gruppe von büchern auf sie dem
produkt begriffen oder den hoch
gegriffen ich jetzt ein bisschen betont
habe also der in der rechten seite
es ist die zweite beiden jugendlichen
mehr bücher lesen als die älteren das
ist jetzt für contra intuitiv kann man
viel über das methodische design
nachdenken aber es könnte jetzt diese
nur für amerika vorhandenen studien noch
verlängern und sie weisen einfach um
genau die andere richtung als das was in
der presse immer wieder behauptet wird
sie kennen den stand in deutschland zum
lesen von der stiftung lesen kim mya
chain studien usw also wirklich ganz
knapp es wird gerade in
deutschsprachigen ländern viel kindern
vorgelesen dass wir wissen alle für die
lesens sozialisation der wichtigste
schritt
ob das 80 prozent sind kann man in frage
stellen weil sie wissen dass es extrem
schwierig zu erheben da gibt es ganz
viele methodische probleme aber
grundsätzlich sind zumindest in
deutschsprachigen ländern die zahlen
deutlich besser als ein anderer
auch die kinder und jugendlichen und
auch die erwachsenen lesen es gibt viele
menschen die jeden tag bücher lesen was
im buch heißt es gibt allerdings auch
ein etwa ein viertel der bevölkerung die
fast nicht liest
sie finden sich eher in der stadt als
auf dem land also es gibt ein klares
bildungsgefälle vom nach unten zur stadt
hin
anders als man denkt wir wissen dass die
lese musste auch noch so typisiert sind
das mädchen frauen ihren emotions betont
sind es geht auf den sozialen medien
nutzung und jungen männer ihre handlungs
betont er sagt text orientiert und das
gleiche
schiri uns in computerspielen wenn auch
nicht so stark und schließlich haben wir
für industrienationen einen erheblichen
anteil und funktionalen analphabeten
da gibt es viele programme wie sie
wissen in den deutschsprachigen ländern
trotzdem haben wir eine zahl die
eigentlich uns die schamesröte in
industrienationen ins gesicht treiben
müsste so nicht sein dürften und der
kinder und jugendlichen auch ganz grob
zusammengefasst die unter 13-jährigen
lesen ungefähr 13
mehr als die hälfte einmal pro woche
ungefähr
sie kennen die ganzen texte dass die
mädchen mehr lesen als die jungs sie
wissen was harry potter und ekstatisch
gregs tagebuch auch die jungs bedeutet
oder ich habe jetzt auch daheim sohn
lesen der bis vor kurzem nicht gelesen
hat aber das lied von feuer und eis also
es gibt gar nicht genug wände und man
muss wirklich so wunderbare dinge tun
wie die taschenlampe unter der bettdecke
wegnehmen und so weiter und es gibt
total glücklich aber spielen natürlich
so aufgeregten vater
weil wir wissen es ist für die lese
sozialisation natürlich in der zweiten
phase in der 4
orientierte phase des erwerbs ganz
wichtig hoher internetkonsum und hohe
schulleistungen schließen einander nicht
aus wenn sie die internationalen studien
vor allem in asiatischen länder sich
angucken die eine viel höhere internet
durchdringung der gesellschaft haben als
wir das in europa haben
und das sage ich sondern die im
börsenverein auch immer wieder irritiert
deshalb werden trotzdem mehr brettspiele
verkauft es gibt etwa in den letzten 20
jahren dreimal so viele klassikfestivals
also wirklich hoch kulturelle ereignisse
als 20 jahre zuvor die zahl der
bibliotheksbenutzer kennt nur eine
tendenz nach oben mit großen regionalen
unterschieden natürlich und 2017 hat das
institut für museumsforschung in berlin
festgestellt dass es in deutschland noch
nie so viele museumsbesucher gegeben hat
wie im jahr 2017 also einige der
vorstellung vom kultur verfallen sind
einfach nur zitate sonst gar nichts an
nichts mit der wirklichkeit zu tun und
ich kann sie nicht mehr sparen auch noch
der intelligenz prozent nimmt seit
jahren im industrienationen zu das ist
sehr gut erforscht seit den 60er jahren
durch james flint und andere und dieser
effekt ist gibt es ganz viele
erklärungen dafür
und das ist ziemlich klar natürlich
steigt das nicht endlos sondern etwa
codekarte um 3
die punkte also wir sind diesen
normalverteilung vermessung und die muss
man etwa alle die karte um drei punkte
nach oben in verschiedene aktionen aber
keine angst wir werden zu keiner super
humans oder so etwas aber trotzdem
kinder werden intelligenter dass es gar
nicht aufzuhalten
und wenn sie jetzt mal ein bisschen über
die zeit gehen das ist jetzt aus der
jeans studie zu sehen unten 2004 und
2008 bis 2017 immerhin von 1200
jugendliche gefragt danach ob sie
mindestens täglich oder mehrmals pro
woche ein buch lesen sehen sie keine
veränderung im leseverhalten im schnitt
etwa 40 prozent der 12 bis 19 jährigen
lesen ca einmal pro woche mindestens ein
buch also kulturverfall hat vielleicht
irgendwo gegeben aber im augenblick
nicht im bereich des lesens in den
deutschsprachigen ländern
so kommen wir also wo sind diese leser
wenn sie nicht automatisch buchkäufer im
sinne des börsenvereins wo sind den und
genau über die möchte ich jetzt sprechen
es gibt so viele möglichkeiten zu lesen
wer sich für musik interessiert es gibt
die klassische akademie ausgabe die mit
wurde durch hewlett packard ins netz
gebracht sehr aufwendig die digitale
mozart ausgabe hat am tag 500 1000
verschiedene zugriffe also man kann bots
und die ähnlichkeit als uns dieselbe ip
adresse ist unterscheiden etwa 500.000
menschen fragen in
pro tag weltweit nach mozart zur
hochkultur bezahlt sind superstar
unserer kultur gar keine frage sie
können heute virtuelle manuskripte wenn
sie sich für hoch spezialisierte dinge
lesen im internet die können sie in der
wirklichkeit nicht lesen wie zb dieses
augustinus manuskript denn diese seiten
dieses manuskript liegen an drei
verschiedenen orten im in sankt
petersburg und paris und an ihren
schreibtisch werden sie durch detlef
technik und es ist wunderbare uni
touristische projekte wo die csu und der
universität fribourg zusammengeführt und
sie lesen das manuskript wieder wie es
im mittelalter einmal war also hoch
spezialisierte interessen haben im
internet möglichkeiten die vor kurzem
nicht da man das sind alles sehr neue
entwicklungen und der größte player ist
natürlich google books sie wissen
vielleicht das motto the page und auch
mal ein bisschen große buch liebhaber
sind und die haben vor allem im scan
technologien investiert das war der
entscheidende durchbruch hier um die
ecke nach zählweise die eigenständige
scanner draußen von der bayerischen
staatsbibliothek geheim räumen darf
neben 300 auf den verträgen nicht sehen
wird im großen stil digitalisiert für
die deutschsprachige bücher die haben
etwa 40 millionen bücher zugänglich von
jetzt gemessen
google an den katalog nummern insbe
änderungen in der library of congress
130 millionen verschiedenen büchern der
welt gibt natürlich weltweit sehr viel
mehr bücher
aber es gibt ihnen eine vorstellung 30
bis 40 millionen bücher sind als
volltext anschließenden party of speed
stacking also sie können dort nach
gucken was ist das wurzelwerk um den
sätzen des chinesischen teenager bücher
und so weiter also solche sachen können
sie alles dort machen das schon riesig
und das entscheidende ist dass diese
bücher massiv herunter geladen werden
hannover hier von der bayerischen
staatsbibliothek verweist immer wieder
darauf dass mehr verschiedene bücher
ausgeliehen werden seit der nur mit
google books teufels partnerschaft aus
sicht vieler bibliotheks kolleginnen
kollegen eingegangen ist aber wer kann
zeigen dass sie zur bildung dieses
landes beigetragen hat weil mehr
menschen mehr verschiedene bücher aus
sein zu wissen von bibliotheken denn
höchstens zehn prozent der vorhandenen
bücher überhaupt jemals ausgeliehen was
ungefähr der wert und mit google books
wird es erweitert also mehr menschen
lesen überhaupt gar keine frage und sie
sind natürlich kaufen nicht bloß neue
bücher und zu auch es gibt es internet
ist wunderbar und man kann bei
booklooker und
vb die inzwischen natürlich von amazon
gekauft warum sind bei dem alle
verstanden haben ein riesiger markt wo
wir eben gebrauchte bücher was immer das
heißt miteinander teilen und es sind
riesige welten leider sehr schwierig
darüber halbwegs zahlen zu bekommen
aber man kann sich aus den reinen
verkaufszahlen wie die gesellschaft für
konsumforschung für den börsenverein das
gemacht hat darauf schließen dass keine
mehr bücher an büchern interessiert ist
denn dann muss die ganzen gebrauchten
bereich sich angucken und der ist
natürlich riesig aber das fertige erste
landschaft und sie sehen dass jemand wie
amazon daran interesse wie hoch dieser
markt dafür tatsächlich ist also dann
ändert sich wirklich sehr viel und jetzt
komme ich zu den dingen die vielleicht
einige von ihnen aus von ihren
schülerinnen und schülern kennen das was
wir was sich deutschen soziales wesen
und schreiben klingt denn wie mit
betreut das lesen und schreiben aber
social medien deuten ist einfach eine
riesige welt was parteien fiction die
selbst verlage da reden wir ja über
einen millionen markt und das will ich
ihnen bisher vorstellen was da passiert
und natürlich gibt es auch
die lovelybooks von großen verlagen also
dass die holtzbrinck-gruppe die dahinter
steht die das organisiert um menschen im
gespräch über bücher zusammen zu bringen
und zwar millionen von menschen zusammen
zu bringen oder bücher treffe wie zum
beispiel das ist wirklich eine wort und
sache sind 50.000 mitglieder
es ist ja nichts die sich selbst das
netz organisiert haben und miteinander
über bücher reden noch ganz
unverständlich so meine kollegen sagen
immer hier aber niemand ist mehr lyrik
akademie für sprache und dichtung und
ein kollege sagt jemand hassemer
kesselbauer nur mal ein beispiel also
hubbauer migranten kennt aus intel mit
vier jahren nach kanada gekommen hat
angefangen wie goethe für geburtstage
jährige zu schreiben so lernt man übrig
zu schreiben dann hat sie mitbekommen es
gibt es internet gibt dienst twitter usw
und hat angefangen ihre gedichte dort zu
publizieren und wurde darüber so populär
dass zu trauern im internet bedeutet
also einfache gedanken in politische
zeilen zu bringen muss man sozusagen
diese berichte sind so erfolgreich dass
zunächst in amerika als sammelband
herausgegeben wurde milk and honey war
wie man eine woche lang
bestseller-autorin auf der new york
times bestsellerliste etwa 1,6 millionen
exemplare verkauft
praktisch alle sprachen übersetzt die
frau ist anfang 20 und hat im deutschen
eine zweisprachige ausgabe deutsch
englisch ich habe auch schon den
verleger kennengelernt und die verkauft
sich natürlich wunderbar dann müssen sie
nur gucken wenn die beim talk auftritt
also so elegant aufzutreten dann muss
noch einiges lernen
obwohl ich sagen würde jetzt mal
literatur ist durch das zweit gegen
kalender lyrik aber kalender lyrik würde
ich nicht verachten denn kalender lyrik
und die lyrischen jahrbücher der
männergesangsverein im neunzehnten
jahrhundert sind eine wichtige instanz
für die verbürgerlichung unserer
gesellschaft und ästhetisierung der
gesellschaft hat hier thomas nipperdey
und seiner großen geschichte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts gezeigt wie das
zusammenhängt also lyrik hat eine
vergesellschaftung funktionen und genau
darum geht es wenn es geht um probleme
in beziehung benachteiligung von mädchen
und vor allem benachteiligung von
mädchen wenn sie nicht so aussehen wie
der standard das verlangt ja und das
sind themen die genau diese funktion
haben die wir im neunzehnten jahrhundert
den irischen jahrbücher die natürlich
auch nicht alle hölderlin gedichte
enthalten haben also es wird weiter
gelesen und geschrieben wie nicht
gescheit main superstar es natürlich
schon queen ist jemand keine görg weiter
da hätte ich wissen muss entschuldigung
okay die nerd reuters als wenn jetzt
kein comeback geben philipp sitzen würde
dann würden wir auch so machen das ist
das erkennungszeichen der zweite song
green ist nicht nur ein wunderbarer
jugend schriftsteller eine besten bei
hansa auch verlegt wird alle bücher
werden auch verfehlt und fast alle
vergeben sondern mit seinem bruder hängt
jetzt auch ein buch herausgebracht hat
sind sie video blogger und erklären jede
woche was passiert da eigentlich in
syrien
darum ist es wichtig nach dem fehlen
wieder in die schule zu gehen und als
auflagen die machen natürlich viele
andere projekte und es ist das buch ist
teil einer digitalen umwelt in der diese
schriftsteller dann auch schriftsteller
sind aber sie sind blogautoren sie
erklären die welt für kinder und
jugendliche in einem maße dass sie eben
millionen von menschen erreichen und das
zu verachten nur weil es nicht nur
literatur ist sondern eben es ganz
selbstverständliches bund ist einfach
teil der digitalen welt
erst kommt das digitale und dann das
buch und nicht die vorstellung wir haben
einen bogen das geht runter und dann
kommt das digitale daneben tragen es ist
genau so isch kandidiere weitermachen es
gibt natürlich völlig industriell
hergestellte des superstars und
schreiben also wie die motorblöcke renzo
land nicht ganz wirklich meinen bereich
aber natürlich super star im internet
und dann müssen natürlich alle leute die
bekannt sind müssen bücher schreiben das
macht sie sich selber sehr dann treffen
steam und ihr debüt roman ist der am
meisten in der ersten woche am teuersten
verkaufte roman in der buch geschichte
so also junge leute lesen in dem fall
dieses zeug aber auch okay sie lesen
das kann man feststellen und dann wird
es natürlich in serie hergestellt und
weitergemacht
schließlich gibt es elaborierter sie
kennen vielleicht twitter romane oder
video blogs das funktioniert so sie
haben einen super star jane austen der
also wirklich in der englischsprachigen
welt sehr wichtig ist oder ein of green
gables also die klassiker und die werden
wieder erzählt von jugendlichen die so
tun als würden lizzy und vista bennett
tweets austauschen also der die
romanhandlung wird entlang der broadline
von jane austen so erzählt das als würde
das jetzt aktuell passieren wird das
medium in dem dieser romane zehn prozent
twitter news oder man nimmt video
es gibt es hoch reguliert reif larsen
ist sicherlich ein sehr engagierter
autor aber sein management sam axe es
vor vier und fünf jahren raus gekommen
kann er nicht mehr drucken sie wissen
dass ein anderen bücher auch nur sehr
schwer noch zu drucken sind aber
entweder es ist ein ex setzt google
street view funktionen voraus sie können
das nur noch auf dem smartphone lesen
sonst verstehen sie eigentlich den
romanischen das geht gar nichts mehr
also es gibt praktisch von der
hochkultur allen
bis zum labor alles in der digitalen
welt und die digitale welt ermöglicht es
lesen und bringt die bücher in einer
umwelt die eben vom börsenverein dass
die ansätze in den blicken 100 dann gibt
es diese ganzen diskussionsforen das ist
völlig willkürlich ausgesucht und
natürlich haben viele meiner kolleginnen
kollegen ja diese lieschen müller reihen
kritik das müssen wir doch gar nicht
ernst nehmen es geht uns doch darum dass
in der faz fällt und die elaborierte
kritik geschrieben wird würde auch hier
mit thomas nipperdey sagen nein es ganz
wichtig dass die menschen selber sich
ihr urteil auf schreiben und sich
schriftlich mit ihren freundinnen sind
immer gleichgesinnte die da
hier miteinander darüber sprechen zb wie
viele kitsch ertragen wir wie viele
klischees dass wenn man diese kritiken
sich genauer anguckt und wir versuchen
das auch mit computergestützten methoden
zu machen sieht man dass es da einen
großen hunger danach gibt
literaturkritische kategorien überhaupt
zu entwickeln und wir versuchen die dort
aus zu finden ist nicht ganz trivial und
nehmen sie was wir jetzt gehe ich mal
auf die amerikanische pop ups da hat
auch goethe dreieinhalb tausend follower
jetzt können sie überlegen ist es viel
oder wenig der team fiction haben sie
natürlich ganz andere zahlen das ist
klar aber immerhin 300.000 dann habe ich
nachgeguckt ein buch das ist zu goethes
lebzeiten ein völliger flop war nämlich
seine erfahrung lehre dass es klappt zu
jetzt könnte man das braun jahr lesen
nicht drin weil sie müssen verstanden
haben wie goethe die farben anordnet um
überhaupt zu verstehen welche bedeutung
die farbe braun hat das sind fachleute
die das lesen
das sind wirklich die hochgebildeten und
die zitieren dann auf die kopieren dann
auch aus akademischen kommentaren wie
sie rechts sehen ganze hinweisen dazu zu
goethes farbenlehre und wenn man da
einfach zu den methoden und jetzt mein
lieblingsbeispiel ist natürlich was ich
hoffe dass kennen sie alle also etwas
70 millionen mitglieder von marie
implikation bis hin zu finishen aber
natürlich ist die englische gruppe die
größte etwa zwei millionen am tag 100
tausend geschichten wieder gelesen
werden und superstars wie einer top
übrigens auch im deutschen übersetzt
beim btb erscheint weil diese bücher
immer kapitelweise auf dem smartphone
auf blocken also wenn sie da mitglied
sind können sie die neueste kapitel von
einer tat die akte sie es schon an
bahnhöfen plakatiert gesehen dass wir
den superstar und am ende einer solchen
serie sagen die leserinnen und leser wie
soll ich weiter reden es genau das was
die leser von umso und achtzehnten
jahrhundert am ende dann wenn ich es
gesagt haben wie kann nicht weiterleben
werden samuel und schließlich nicht
bekommen haben ja mein leben hat keinen
sinn mehr
das ist das sind die rechten leser das
ist nämlich die massiven leser und die
finden sie dort im großen stil und es
ist kein zufall dass genau der
kanadische gründer der ganzen sache erst
eine digitale umwelt gebaut hat dann im
sinne der plattform industrie gesagt
haben die leute bilden selber den
content obwohl die da auch klassiker
drin haben und dann tauschen sie sich
darüber aus und jetzt mache ich auch
noch im verlag des landes nachgeordnet
das was wir als klassisches buch kenne
das auch an der torte und andere dann
gedruckt werden aus diesen welten ist
hat der zweite schritt erst ist erstmal
die umwelt und das bringt mich dann zum
einschluss thema ein bisschen auf die
zeit achten also die folgen für die
forscher die nicht ganz trivial sind
also zusätzlich vorstellen
so sieht es auf ihrem smartphone aus ja
ein neues kapitel in der vorbereitung
pratchett ist
kosten also werden die klassiker dort
auch gewesen
wir ziehen diese geschichten runter
staates creating heißt es habe dazu
geschrieben dass es nicht ganz konform
mit der datenschutz grund verordnung
aber wir machen es trotzdem
dann sehen sie dafür kleine bar
hausrechts den text es gibt dann an das
neben einem satz wie mein team ist
manager des lady jaye monday have heard
in der so viele parks of last etwa 315
kommentare nur zu diesem einzelnen satz
da sind das ungefähr die höhe
und wir müssen die daraus kriegen diese
sätze also wir laden den text herunter
geladen die kommentare dazu unter die
kommentare die ja wieder kommentare zu
kommentaren sind also das sind der
interne diskussionen
also hier 342 nur zu einem einsatz da
drin also wir reden am ende über
zehntausende von kommentaren und
versuchen darüber ganz zu verstehen
wie gehen menschen junger mensch
mit klassischen büchern um dem
unterschiedlichen also wenn sie sehen
schon am teambewerb boys girls und
erklären uns geht
im unterschied zum großen oder
shakespeare und übrigens von den
deutschen autoren hermann hesses einfach
immer grün immer noch unterwegs und wir
wollen eben verstehen ob trotzdem erst
mal eine zahl die im centro 42.000
kommentaren es ist gar nichts gehört hat
25 millionen kommentare also das ist
schon ein bisschen mehr traffic da ob
die sich also von der zahl von ihrer
struktur wie weit gehen die aufeinander
ein und vor allem verwenden sie andere
sprache denn wir gehen von das cap
holding theorie aus dass der
ausgangstext wenn wir schon schwieriger
ist auch die sprache der kommentare
schwieriger ist also dieses gerüst war
und diese skeptisch geworden
genau das untersucht und der daniel
defoe aus und gerade frisches paper das
ist hoffentlich angenommen wird wo wir
gucken und wie junge menschen von den
polstern oder meistertitel sichern wie
viele gehen lieber und schenker oder
patches oder rosa es zu kommentieren
also wie weit diese welten ineinander
über wie weit sind sie überhaupt separat
also was passiert da überhaupt an
bildungsprozessen die jenseits der
schule selbst organisiert erst in
digitalen welten möglich geworden sind
das sind wir am anfang da gibt es
einfache maße also komplexität maße wie
flash index und andere die sagen wie
viele worte sind durchschnittlich in
einem satz da wie lang sind diese worte
usw
und da können sie dann einzelne
kommentare san machen wieviele jahres im
amerikanischen schulsystem gegangen sein
müssen als zwischen 9 bis 13 jahre und
diese rezension auf der rechten seite
stehen zu können das ist die kombination
also am ende wollen wir bildungsprozesse
besser verstehen die aber im digitalen
passieren und die wir zum ersten mal so
zu sagen echtzeit abgreifen können
die han vilsheim data hier in einem
maßstab den wir bis vor kurzem nicht
hatten und das bildern immer
raffinierter also wir versuchen
sogenannte blood lines zu rekonstruieren
und
genau da kommt die ruhe ist die
emotionale linie also man die wörter in
positive und negative wörter und
neutraler wird ein und schneidet dann
die romane in etwa 10.000 wort slice und
guckt dann immer es dominieren die
negativen oder die positiven wörter oder
ist neutral
im duell mit linien und bekommt dann ein
emotionales profil was uns in etwa dem
verlauf eine geschichte da und gucken
dann ob das sich widerspiegelt in den
kommentaren also emotional aufgeladene
szenen die sie meistens dabei er zurück
ist dann entsprechend viel kommentar
dazu
usw das sind so ein bisschen die neuen
methodischen ansätze die wir machen das
geht natürlich nur computer generiert
weil die regierung über millionen von
datenpunkten also wenn es im
karteikarten machen wollen dann ist das
was wir brauchen ist dazu und holding se
aus dem bereich von paid nation building
staates oxford und die diskurs
aggression support systemen unter kost
auf sehr starke linguistisch
psychologisch wollen wir verstehen
einen vorschlag wie erwerben eines
kinder die fähigkeit zu erzählen wie
baut es auf einen drauf da gibt es keine
zusammenhängende theorie soweit ich
sehen
ich hoffe sie korrigieren mich wie
funktioniert das überhaupt können wir
das klassifizieren wo sehen wir in
welchen altersgruppen dessen haupt und
wie funktioniert dieses gerüst bilden
von gemeinsamen bilder punkt lesen mit
der mama bis hin zu groß also das ist
eigentlich was wir als einheit sehen und
nicht als eingeteilt in hochkultur und
sogenannte populäre kultur
aber da sind man den anfängen da gibt es
viele ich kann es nur ganz kurz machen
apps auf handys von jugendlichen zu
spielen um deren nutzungsverhalten
abzugreifen weil da müssten sie
zustimmen sonst haben wir unser
datenschutzprobleme wir halten uns mit
100 fragebögen zur
persönlichkeitsstruktur wir wissen das
persönlichkeitsmerkmal einen hohen
einfluss darauf haben wie gewesen wird
wie sich lesen biografien entwickeln wir
versuchen das auch im rahmen von
allgemeinem wohlbefinden gesellschaft
also wie verändert sich gesellschaftlich
sozial politische ansatz wenn sie das
vor einem burgenland holding skater und
so weiter sich anfangen da geht es darum
am ende auf unsere gesellschaft besser
wird ganz simpel aufklärerisch ist das
gemeint also solches kann mit denen wir
das versuchen zu ermessen ist also
standardisiertes kann
wir brauchen gemeinsame texten modellen
also wie beschreibt
ihre texte also den usa zwängen oder
nutzen wir auch kategorien wie
komplement setzte und das ganze bringt
mich dann zum schluss
wir sind in einem alexandrien zeitreise
so nenne ich das in meinem hoffentlich
bald kommen ein buch gelesen im
digitalen zeitalter die elektronisch
deshalb weil wir zum ersten mal diese
riesigen leser wählten erfassen können
die vor kurzen noch nicht da waren aber
es ist klar es gibt viele dieser laser
wir haben neue methoden diese daten auch
zu erheben und zu analysieren die vor
kurzem also damit meist letzten fünf
jahren noch nicht da war
die sind sehr stark quantitativ das
finden viele meiner kollegen und
kolleginnen aus dem ursprünglichen fach
der germanistik nicht gut sind nicht
primär um 90 sehr stark statistisch
psychologisch wir haben große probleme
mit personalisierten daten datenschutz
werde jetzt gelernt ein großer teil
unserer forschung illegal ist was machen
sie dann für forscher sind leider auch
gelobt wir haben noch kein text modell
mit denen wir uns alle verständigen um
unsere daten miteinander vergleichen zu
können und wir würden sagen vielleicht
ist so was was man scaffold der theorie
das ist ja ein größeres theorien
konglomerat ein integratives
forschungskonzept und überhaupt auch
weltweit
also wir noch bei nordkorea zusammen zu
verstehen was einigen
es passiert ja und das war jetzt habe
ich ein bisschen überzogen
der kostenvergleich zu machen
er wirkt ein bisschen architekten marcel
zu werden
diese sind
haben
[Musik]
der stadt eingetragen ist
du weißt schon
die partei arbeiten
das alles nicht
die nationalstraße sich überlegen
[Musik]
ich muss er hin der für die macht oder
sich frei
dann im englischen
dabei auf gebiet wurde das ist eben zu
viel
dieser liegt über alles lieben
sprache laufenden jahr schon aus dem
experten kritisch oder national stark
was wenn der bildung passieren soll
die nationalsprachen also steht eine
gute
allerdings ist es nicht der daten dazu
wir müssen patienten die von
europäischen sprachen intermec
skeptische sprache
aus der schrift ist in dem job zudem das
englische ton bild und im englischen
ardian alle diese als kritischer
skizzierung und damit immer sehen wollen
allerdings gibt es mal ganz anderen
da drehen sie müssen als vielfalt 1
während welches popstars superstars im
tecdax sind oder wer man geld in sanders
und verstehen sie viele ihrer texte
die haben natürlich nichts hohen grad
von populären
die angestellte kommen
die frage ist das eigentliche hauptact
andere interessierte so was die crown
oder dann hier und dort auch nicht
das
einsteigen in den alpen krimis die
anderen steine ist und den coolen
kritisch sehen
diese schichten
was gibt es denn überhaupt ball
abwechselnd geräumt zuschauer es also
einen bildungsqualität wenn ich darin
geben wenn kinder und jugendlichen der
lag es für verschiedene genres um sich
auszudrücken
das würden wir das verstehen ich kann es
noch nicht in zahlen geben um zum
beispiel in frankreich angesteckt haben
diesen spielen eine rolle spielt in
deutschland zusammen aber ein köstliches
gericht in tucson es trete unserem geld
nicht aus können sondern die stadt
weniger auf englisch weil sie damit der
welt gekommen und die wissen
diese karrieren von anfang 20 jährige
näherin also selbst grafischen bereich
ist natürlich nach haben die
geschäftswelt
das war eine frage werde noch ein
bisschen zeit
[Musik]
analysierendes portale im ort unterwegs
als das menschliche textfassung nehmen
diese ganze reihe kategorien
das heißt die kino um des textes
erscheinungsfest verständlichkeit oder
sie besuchen
wir wollen kindern beizubringen dass im
sechsten krieger und hat und damit es
nicht so die überschrift gemeint aber
auch solche kategorien die complement
setzen
sehr interessiert das sind sätze wie ich
denke sie ab gestern gesagt er habe in
vier tagen also muss in mehreren
perspektiven ineinander abbilden und das
problem ist dass diese kommt
methoden darauf passieren dass das immer
in der oberfläche angreifen
ein großteil unserer sprache passiert
hinter dem wochen und es heißt wir
müssen das ist das hauptproblem in den
sog
forschungsmethoden einen weg finden
hier an der oberfläche die dinge reifen
und ein wichtiger beschluss 2 gegen
verfolgung ist welche wertungskategorien
also wie stark ist ein traum dass ich
den patienten kann das ist die welt um
sich herum vergessen besuchen
wesentlich moderner lesen so macht seine
400 aufgeräumt und das zu erfassen weil
die benutzten zwar gelegentlich auch
solche leben erziehen oder ich habe
nicht immer vergessen
aber das wird in ganz verschiedenen
weisen aus reaktoren wie finden sie
einem fortbestehen und jetzt allein
die kategorie des intensiven lesen oder
wie finden sie ist ihm beschwert urteile
unterstützen so genannten erwähnte zu
schlichten und teilen von besonders
viele dieser bücher dem business
ausgelesen sozialisation erst einmal auf
das eigene leben abgebildet werden
bevor solche kategorien kommen also hier
ist der erzähler wirklich benutzt viele
indirekte freie rede oder so also die
keine solche wertungskategorien
überhaupt erfassen
ebenso unterschiedliche sprache von
jugendlichen der verschiedenen
altersgruppen ausgebaut wird
im hauptteil der forschungs problematik
ist wir haben das sozusagen eine theorie
und die kriegen wird der theorie
formalisiert und wir sagen dazu
modernisierte modernisierungsprozesses
computergestützten methoden zentral so
unter das wir aus millionen von fans
sagen können die menschen also junge
leser ab wir werden zunächst einmal was
hat es mit meinem leben zu tun
ist das tatsächlich so und natürlich mit
uns mehreren ganz einfach
wir gehen dorthin werden mit der bavaria
technisches projekt gemacht mit
abschlussklassen jugendlichen
wir schreiben unsere nächstenliebe es
normal auch ihre vorstände
ganz sicher ist er aber ein wunderbarer
haben wir wirklich eine bestimmte gruppe
die wir sehen und kennen doch ein paar
tausend mitgemacht haben auch einmal
selber geschrieben haben
vielen dank
da fangen wir ist allerdings ist anderes
ich kann eigentlich kein ergebnis
[Musik]